if you over prioritize uh making money
you're going to lose out i ultimately
think on much larger opportunities
because you're going to make short-term
oriented decisions rather than
long-term-oriented decisions
the bigger the mission you go after
ironically enough the more people show
up to help you because it's actually
worthwhile pursuing
star trek is here it's happening
and here we go hey there how's it going
i've never done this before
glad to be on all right instagram live
we're popping your cherry i love it
ladies and gentlemen this is dakin he is
from prime
movers lab venture capitalists just
raised
245 million dollars for their
second fund and we're going to talk
today about what he's up to
uh how to raise capital and all the
crazy breakthroughs that he's going
through
uh with this fund they can welcome
aboard man thanks for having me evan
thanks for uh
introducing me to instagram live too i
love it hey
you are into some crazy breakthrough
science you know instagram live is not
that that big a breakthrough but uh i
love it i love that we can we can do it
dude i was looking through your
your portfolio and everything you're up
to and
most of it is just way above my head in
terms of ability to
understand and knowledge and comprehend
um and i guess that's kind of the point
in what you're doing right like you're
actually going after
breakthrough science and taking on
industries where most
vcs kind of don't touch is that
the business model yeah exactly so uh
i had built two tech companies before
and what i really realized is there was
this lack of investor focus on
breakthrough scientific inventions
so that's what we focus on it's things
like energy transportation
infrastructure manufacturing biotech and
these are the things that can actually
make a real difference to the average
human being's life
and i think if we look over the next 30
years these are the types of tech
companies that are going to define not
just financial returns
but huge contributions to humanity and
that's really why we started the firm
you look at your instagram you've got
like bionic arms and you've got you know
space projects and all it's like it's
star trek is here it's happening with
everything you guys are making it's
amazing
we're investing in things that sound
like science fiction but are actually
reality here today and now
and we've got like this team of
scientists that let us go really deep in
all of these areas so we can distinguish
between the stuff that's
you know too far out to be realistic
today but it's like the star trek of
today where you're going to actually
have results for the average human
being well let's talk about that because
i think a lot of
vcs would think it's too far away
i'm not going to get a return we can't
commercialize fast enough and i know
your your focus is on commercialization
and good for humanity
right it's like that combination so so
for everybody's like it's way too far
away
how are you speeding up the time to
commercialization
well i think it's a great point there's
these three big myths that exist out
there about hardtack or deep tech or
breakthrough science whatever you want
to call it
and it's that it takes longer that it's
higher risk and that it's more capital
intensive
and i actually believe and we've shown
this with the performance of our first
fund
that the opposite is true if you're
investing in these things at the right
stage
where the ip has already been
demonstrated it's already working
but they haven't yet turned it into a
product that the market wants to consume
these can actually be faster to market
lower risk and less capital intensive
and that's why our first fund
is up uh over 8x in just under three
years
because we've picked companies that have
these kind of crazy sounding things like
in-space
transportation or industrial solar heat
or aquaponics farming or a chronovirus
vaccine
and we've invested at that inflection
point where they're now ready to
commercialize it and that that's i think
the whole key
we've got about a dozen uh scientists
between our team actually a few dozen
scientists between our team
and outside advisors that are the world
leading thinkers in each of these areas
so we can go really deep really fast and
figure out is this one of those ones
that's about to pop
so is it just that you guys have a
better team than the other vcs out there
well i i think there's really two things
we we are really grateful for the
opportunity to be able to contribute to
the world
one is the level of scientific depth we
have you know i'm a physicist by
background
and then we have a team of people who
are much much smarter than me evaluating
these things
and then we also i think go really deep
with our founders so
uh the two the second piece is service
we have
uh partners who are focused on executive
coaching
psychology i know you had one of our
partners tony on uh
recently um we've got folks doing
government relations pr
talent all these things because it's not
enough to just give somebody a capital
really these founders need support
advice and real partnership and
friendship to help them build their
company and we roll up our sleeves and
get in the trenches with people kind of
doing whatever it takes
to make sure they not only succeed but
they enjoy the process
talk about getting partners i know so
you mentioned tony's that's tony robbins
uh for everybody you know kind of
watching may not be may not know who
tony is
um you've got astronauts as part of your
team like how did you go off
with this mission of yours to create
this fund and
attract all these amazing humans to want
to join in
well actually one one of the ceos i've
backed before says something i think is
really relevant here blake scholl who
founded a boom supersonic this is a
supersonic uh
jet company it's just as hard to go
build a company that's going after
something small
as something that's big and in some ways
it's actually easier to go build a
company that's going after a big thing
because it inspires people around you to
want to get involved right
and that's from the team that's from
advisors that's from investors
so the bigger the mission you go after
ironically enough the more people show
up to help you because it's actually
worthwhile pursuing
you know what i love about you is um
i've talked to a lot of vcs
and you feel more like an entrepreneur
than a vc if that makes sense it's like
absolutely i mean the way this started i
was sitting in the hot tub with my wife
and i was kind of complaining about how
broken vc was in this particular sector
yeah and she's like you're an
entrepreneur that's a problem fix the
problem build a product or a service
and so we did like i i think of us as
entrepreneurs who are building a product
and service
for founders and that product is prime
movers lab where
the least useful thing we provide is the
capital it's all the other supplementary
technical expertise uh portfolio support
um coaching
that makes us uh really uh not
not an investment shop but company
builders who happen to have pre-raised
some capital
so where do scientists or
or kind of entrepreneurs with the
science background where do they
struggle
when they're trying to raise capital
there's a lot of places
i think uh historic historically uh you
know
if you do a phd and become an expert in
neuroscience or something like that
you may be very good at communicating to
an academic audience
but you may not know how to tell a
business story and how to market
kind of what the commercial opportunity
is so that's one thing that we often
even even like i think these are simple
things that when you
frame what your mission is is to serve
founders it's really different than if
your mission is to invest in founders
those are
subtle subtle shifts but really
important and of course we end up
investing in founders
but in the diligence process we'll often
be interacting with a founder
and we'll be giving them feedback and
advice about how they can be telling
their story better
from the first pitch even if they
haven't committed to work with us we
haven't committed to work with them
so that they get that benefit as they're
pitching to multiple investors and i
think
uh that's one simple example uh there's
all the operational pieces right
you're not prepared necessarily uh if
you've built some
amazing breakthrough to uh to sell to
market
uh to hire and so we have kind of all
the resources you need across the
spectrum
to prepare to deal with each of those
challenges which frankly are
uh you know you don't need to reinvent
the wheel people have figured out how to
do those things
and you can take playbooks and copy
those and apply them to the particular
business that's being built how much of
a business
background do you think somebody has to
have like when they're pitching a video
someone's pitching you hey
you just raised 245 million dollars now
you got all these people
emailing you and say hey i want some of
that deakin give me some
uh what are you looking for
so yes the hardcore tech the
breakthrough science
what else are you looking for from the
founder and how much of it of a team and
complete package do they need to have
so we evaluate companies on four
criteria so the first criteria
is the founder and the founding team the
management team around them and so we're
looking for people who really are
relentless
and they're willing to take feedback
those are like the two most important
criteria i think in any successful
founder
because when you when you start a
company you're really going after this
like huge vision
and you need to be laser focused i'm
going to do whatever it takes to make
sure that this vision succeeds
but you need to be really flexible and
adaptable to what's the pathway to
getting to that success
because you're gonna learn from your
customers you're gonna learn from
investors you're gonna learn from your
team learn from partners
things that are often the exact details
about how to get to that
so that's that's the first piece the
second piece is
the technology of course there needs to
be real defensible intellectual property
for our particular investment thesis and
the way that we invest
third is the business and so uh you know
often founders will come to us
that are clearly in love with the
science of what they've done
and they happen to be building a
business that tends not to be the right
uh exact founder for us we want folks
who really want to make an impact on the
world that are wanting to make a big
contribution and
they see the business as a vehicle to
scale their science out to serve
humanity and so there has to be a big
market there has to be a big pain point
and there's to be thoughtfulness about
the business they don't have to have all
the answers you're not gonna have all
the answers at the beginning
but there has to be an orientation
towards that and then of course we're
investing at a stage where we're putting
in
two to five million dollars so this
would be kind of an early stage company
that's just at the beginning of that
commercialization pathway
for the first one of taking feedback how
do
how do you test for that is that do you
have do you have
tests or hoops that you throw people
through or is it just a
vibe that you get when you first meet
them yeah i think you get a vibe at
first but we
we give people feedback during the
process
and we see how they incorporate it and
you know there's varying levels of
reaction to that
so if somebody's got like a very strong
sense of ego
uh they might be quite resistant and
that that's quite obvious um
kind of the the best founders tend to oh
uh say something like oh thank you
that's like really useful information
and
they don't like i'm not saying uh i i'm
not arrogant enough to think that we
have the answers or that we we know the
right way to do things
i think that we can be a useful partner
in discussing things and so
they may come back and reflect on that
and say actually this piece i think
really applies this piece doesn't apply
so much
and we love that because we on the other
end of the spectrum you can have people
who are like
uh i'm just gonna do whatever you tell
me to do and that's not the right
founder mentality either they need to be
critical thinkers
in choosing feedback from many different
sources and identifying
this is the parts that i'm going to
implement how often do you have to
take them out of the ceo role yeah
we don't view there's definitely vc
firms that uh that's their orientation
that's what they're gonna do
yeah at the end of the day we're backing
founders with a great technology and
business opportunity
and if the founder uh isn't like this is
what we're trying to assess with the
feedback piece
if the founders not performing we will
come and deliver them feedback
and we will try and support them in
developing them and getting them to the
place where they can
tackle the challenge out of them if they
can't we will at a certain point say
hey we don't think that you're the right
person to be running this we think you
should bring in a partner or an ally
that helps you do this and complement
your skill set but if they're not
willing to do that we're not going to
force them to do that we're not in the
business of forcing uh ceos out
at that point we're going to focus our
attention resources somewhere else that
is accepting the feedback and is
accepting the guidance that we're
providing right
is that something that's already kind of
you're road mapping it when you're first
meeting them like before you even sign a
deal it's like hmm
okay is this the person who can actually
build a hundred million dollar company
plus at those first conversations we're
discussing with them
not just where do they want their
company to be and what kind of outcome
do they want to produce for the world
but what do they want to become and
often with scientific founders they're
very upfront like
i'm the cto i'm the chief scientist i
happen to be holding the ceo right now
role right now at some point we're going
to need to bring in a ceo
and that's that's fantastic we're very
comfortable with that as long as the
person is self-aware
reflective and introspective where
they're considering what's right for the
business you know there's a great phrase
uh do you want to be rich or you want to
be king and it's like a little crass but
i think it captures the point
where uh do you want to see your
technology make a meaningful difference
to hundreds of millions or billions of
people around the world
and at a certain point if it turns out
that you you're
holding that title and you're uh guiding
the ship
isn't the right answer are you willing
to give it up and that's that's
something we always ask founders
to understand what's the motivation is
it about them or is it about the mission
what do you think some of the biggest
mistakes these founders are making when
they're pitching
vcs or maybe maybe like a vc like you
might have a slightly different way of
operating
yeah i think i think one subtle easy
thing that people can do is
listen to the language that the other
party is using so if i'm
presenting to an investor that's a
potential investor for us the first
thing i always do is i ask them as many
questions as i possibly can
to the point where they they might even
get a little bit annoyed that i haven't
started talking i haven't started
communicating
but i'm hearing i'm hearing what matters
to them i'm hearing
what successes they've had when they
were investing in similar things what
failures they've had so i know which
things to avoid
uh focusing on and i'm getting as much
information from them before i start
telling my story as possible
because then i know how to communicate
my story in a way that's fitting for
them
and i might even assess in that period
like hey like this actually isn't even a
good person and be like really blunt
about that like
uh we're probably not a fit for you i
don't want to waste your time and
i think we often have this mindset when
we're trying to convince someone of
something
of presuming that we know that we how to
convince them up front
we generally do because we've told our
story a lot but our story has to be
customized
to that person's mindset to that
person's psychology to what matters to
them
i love your vibe i love the entrepreneur
mindset that you have
talking about you're stepping up
in front of the camera and doing
instagram lives like
vcs aren't doing this kind of stuff
right like how i know it's not about the
ego on you
and you know look at me deacon so so why
the
push to come in front of the camera and
spread the message the message
yeah i mean look it's definitely it's
definitely not about me uh if it was
just like a personal preference i
probably wouldn't do this i'm not like a
very uh public-facing person
uh as you can tell by the fact that i've
never done an instagram live um
that being said i think the mission that
our companies are on is so important for
the world
as i said we've got companies that are
feeding the planet they're providing
clean energy
that are taking us off to new worlds
that are ending the pandemic
and i think it's important to spread the
message about those companies
and i think uh i think of each of us as
vehicles to accomplish on purpose here
and so i'm a vehicle to help attract
great capital to those types of founders
that wouldn't necessarily be flowing
there so these important missions can
happen and
this is a there's a small piece in uh
doing that i appreciate you giving us
the opportunity to do that
um so that we can we can get the word
out there and we can get more phenomenal
founders funded that are working on
really mission critical problems
one of the things i talk to my audience
a lot about is making money has got to
be
in your top five list of priorities if
you're an entrepreneur but it can't be
number one
like there's the mission and the purpose
of number one and then money has to be
two to five but if it's too far down the
list
you don't have a business either because
you gotta make money i think a lot of
people have the perspective of vcs as
just being
cutthroat do whatever it takes to make
money
how do you balance the purpose
of the companies you're investing into
and the mission with the
need to make money to keep it growing
yeah
i think it's it's what you said it's
about order so
everyone wants to have a purpose
everyone wants to make money like those
are just universal things meeting basic
human needs that we have
the order matters a lot though if if you
over
prioritize making money you're going to
lose out i ultimately think on much
larger opportunities
because you're going to make short-term
oriented decisions rather than long-term
oriented decisions
if you focus on the big picture what's
the mission what's the state of the
world that i want to create
and it's an inspiring large uh state of
the world and there's a big gap there
you're going to produce plenty of plenty
of financial results too
you have to be thoughtful about those
things you have to be strategic and
tactical
but uh yeah i think i think this is
fundamentally one of the biggest
problems with vc
is vc has historically been far too
oriented towards
using founders as uh as their products
basically
rather than delivering a product to
founders to help them achieve their
mission
and uh as i said like our first fund is
right now on track to be one of the best
performing funds of 2018
less than three years after starting the
firm so i i think that
we have this notion that these are like
uh things we have to choose between we
don't have to choose between them
if we go after big missions and we
figure out how to serve a lot of people
um you know tony says this i don't know
if you said it when he was on with you
but
business is the ultimate spiritual game
you're trying to figure out how to add
more value than anybody else in the
marketplace
and if you do that for a large number of
people with a valuable product
you're going to produce great financial
results too you know as i look at you
i see the two differences in that one
you're
just the mindset and the mantra and the
and the caring for entrepreneurs and
and not just investing into them but
being their partner but then also kind
of like the deep
tech hardcore science that people are
afraid to jump into
um that might be a little harder to
emulate but the whole actually caring
about founders
is that something that you hope
permeates
vc culture and people start looking at
you as the model
well i don't need them to look at us as
the model but i uh i hope that it
permeates the culture and i think
to be fair there are other vcs out there
that take that approach in that mindset
as well
you know a good friend is uh joe
lonsdale who founded vc and they do they
do this really well in enterprise
software and bio attack and logistics
so they're they're definitely uh
founder-friendly firms out there they're
they're too far and a few between and i
think as we see a proliferation of
people
building startups we're going to see a
proliferation of this mindset and
expansion of those minds then it's
already starting to happen
for someone who's trying to raise like
if it's two to five million that they're
going to
get you know from your fund what's the
process like to apply is it just
go to your website there's an email send
us your your
executive summary is it you have to be
introduced like how are you actually
fielding most of your
inquiries yeah so we see about 3 000
deals a year
and uh definitely there's a weighting in
our preference to somebody who's made
the effort of getting an introduction
somehow through their network
versus uh just applying online and there
happens to be a higher quality
because look uh social proof matters um
social proof
is important to kind of validating
things and
it also it also shows it's not that hard
to get an intro to us you know like we
have big networks
um and uh if you didn't take the time to
do that it kind of
uh it can feel a little like lazy but
like look we look at everything
and we we do a quick screen where we're
evaluating founders on some of the
things we talked about before
because that's the easiest thing to
assess the business the deal
the technology those take more time but
the people i think you can form very
quick evaluations of what what's driving
people what's important to people
and it doesn't take a lot you just have
to ask a simple question what's
important to you
and just for people who maybe haven't
done a deal before if somebody's raising
the 2 to five million from you guys what
kind of percentage roughly are they
looking at giving up
it really depends on the stage of the
company and what they've accomplished so
far from a technical milestones
and from a commercialization perspective
but at a seed stage like that you're
generally selling between 10 and 25
of the company depending on where you're
at yeah
that's actually pretty good
yeah look at that we we want to be
aligned with our ceos and we want to
make sure they have tons of ownership
because they're going to be driving the
bus to success
and are people usually already having
angels when they come to you are you
trying to
just be a super angel almost coming in
at a much higher
valuation again it we've done some very
early stage deals where we're the first
money in
often though there's been grant money
that's gone into these types of
uh technologies and non-dilutive funding
either from universities or from
government
that have gotten them to the point where
they can now go raise institutional
capital
would there be any i think a lot of
people make mistakes in the early stages
of their business giving up
too much equity to a bad partner to a
bad angel
just throwing a whole bunch of equity at
a dentist who gave them
half a million for their business or
whatever are there any kind of no-gos
when when you look at them like i like i
love this person what they're doing but
just
the mistakes they've made with raising
in the past is just preventing you from
making an investment
yeah i mean we we definitely look at
what the cap table is and
are the people who are working on the
business the majority owners of the
business
so that incentives are aligned and that
value creation is aligned
um i wouldn't say that there's like hard
and fast rules there but
there's often what will happen in these
situations that's a good example of
particularly med companies
is professor founders who are working
very part-time will have way too big of
chunks of ownership
um and like people don't often think
about equity right at the beginning
because
they think about what's the value that's
been created to date and sure the
professor probably has driven most of
the value to date
but if the professor is not quitting
their job and working on this full-time
uh they're not driving most of the value
going forward and equity grants are
in proportion to what's the future value
that's going to be created
not to what the past value has been so
would you go into a situation like that
and say hey
um i love this company but professor you
have to go from 50 down to 10
if we're going to make a deal yeah we'll
we'll say that
we'll say it kindly and lovingly and
right and and with humility that we may
be wrong
someone else may fund them anyways um
but just like those
i think i think one thing that uh people
get really off on with feedback is like
that's like not a that's not a nice
message to hear necessarily as the
professor
but it's an important like we'd be doing
them a disservice if we didn't tell them
that
because if we just like oh no it's not a
fit like they're not actually learning
from that process
and by communicating what are the things
that are not a fit
with care and with compassion i think
we're ultimately serving founders even
if we don't end up investing with them
and and that's for me what it's all
about it's not
like i love that love the companies that
we invest in uh the mission's much
broader than that though it's as you
said
having a investor ecosystem that focuses
on compassion and on being friendly to
founders
and what i love about that is you're not
just saying no but then they don't know
how to fix it or what the problem is
because
that's what they're probably getting
from all the other vc's too is just to
know but
they're sitting there thinking hey we
got this great product or service that
but they don't know how to go off and
prove it i love that you're giving
feedback even if you're not gonna
invest um dude it's crazy how time flies
when
when you're having fun yeah definitely
if people want to
learn more about you or or um prime
movers or
like where do you want them to go we can
link that up in the in the description
of the youtube video where do you want
them to
hit you guys up on yeah i think our our
website's a great spot to start
primemoverslab.com and there's a contact
email there if people want to get in
touch
awesome well i'm super excited to see
all of the crazy
inventions that you are bringing out and
if you can combine star trek
with the humanity and with the force for
good
man i'm i don't understand the science
but i'm i'm cheering you on
from the sidelines trying to send
entrepreneur love your way so thank you
for the time i really appreciate it love
your soul and
i'm just pumped for what you're doing
thank you thank you for what you're
doing and uh just
a pr uh pleasure to be on thanks deakin
take care
bye cheers if you want to see the
one-on-one i did with tony robbins check
out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there the quality of
your life has nothing to do with how
much money you have how many beautiful
children you have how many people love
you
the quality of your life is where you
live emotionally this is the time to
retool
it's a time for you to say where's the
world now